in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week dr. Kim thanks so much
for inviting me into your clinic I
believe in myself and I see lots of
patients with muscle cramps especially
in the calves so why is the muscle
cramps happens in the carbs the muscle
cramps usually occur after physical
exertion and so probably that's one of
the reasons why it's in the cows because
we're doing exercise so what role does
magnesium play many of my patients want
me to prescribe the magnesium to get rid
of the crab's it has a role in treating
plant cramps so magnesium is electro one
of the electrolytes that we need in our
body and we get it from liquids from
vegetables and if the magnesium level is
lower than cramps occur more often and
other crimes actually originating from
the muscle cells themselves or do they
originate from the nerve cells they
originate from the nerves the nerves
innervate the muscles and they activate
our muscles but if the nerves are
hyperactive than our muscles can get
cramps okay you had a lot of questions
from our viewers and Richard swam from
Sydney in Australia wants to know if
organs can cram as well he means at the
heart because the heart is a muscle so
can the heart muscle cramp and then we
die no the heart muscle doesn't cramp
it's our skeletal muscle that can have
these cramps and the other organs don't
have the same type of muscles so do we
need to be frightened when we have some
muscle cramps are they say a sign for
most severe disease no generally not of
course some disease go along with a
higher likelihood of getting muscle
cramps but in general if you have a
muscle cramp at night it's not a sign of
having a
very severe disease so they're just
painful and you can they are painful yes
to go through it and it's a big museum
that's you specializing in a special
form of crabs which are which is called
dystonia
what is this tell me all about it I
dystonia is an movement disorder its
leads to abnormal positioning posturing
there are different regions that can be
effective can be the eye so your eyelids
it's so called blepharospasm or even
more often it's your hat the head so you
can have a tilt of your head or rotation
of the head as a cervical dystonia
but also a very specific dystonia that
only occurs with using your hand like
writing so a writer's cramp or musician
dystonia when the pianist plays and gets
a cramp or at this toni of those fingers
for example but it can also be the whole
body affected which we call them a
generalized dystonia that's the most
severe form of dystonia it is dystonia
painful dystonia is painful as well
because it is an abnormal positioning of
your body and over the time it gets
painful for the patient as well so
dystonia is a very frequent disease it's
a rare disorder in general and it
depends whether it's a generalized
dystonia that's really very rare it's
just 0.5% of a hundred thousands and the
focal dystonia are slightly more often
like the numbers are very different
that's that are given but about ten
200,000 if you suffer from muscle cramps
they go away by themselves after a few
minutes but with Estonia it's a total
different story isn't it yes it is
dystonia is completely different
disorder so they don't go away by
themselves but you can't treat the
dystonia yes you can treat Estonia and
for focal dystonia which means only a
specific region of the body is involved
in dystonia they can be treated by
botulinum toxin injections so that means
it as an injection into the affected
muscles and
it inhibits the activation of the muscle
and thereby the dystonia is relieved
however it's not completely gone so it's
the same battling toxin of Botox you
recognize from cosmetic procedures where
people have wrinkles on the Forex for
example and you just inject some Botox
to get it flattened so it's the same you
do that's the thing yes but we need it
for the muscles that are involuntary
activated during dystonia and usually it
needs about three to five days to start
its action and then after 10 to 12 weeks
to about 3 months new injection has to
be made from lifelong Bennigsen yes so
but there is a different treatment
option available next to the Botox
treatment which is called deep brain
stimulation yeah that it's a new
treatment option since about 25 years
now and it is a very effective treatment
in patients with generalized or
segmented Estonia as you can imagine you
can't have your botulinum toxin
injections all over the body and it is
the treatment where we or the
neurosurgeon implants lead electrodes
into the brain in deep brain structures
of the so called basal ganglia that are
involved in the pathophysiology of
dystonia so it is a network disorder
between the surface of the brain and
deep brain structures that organize our
action or voluntary actions and if
there's a malfunctioning of this network
then the dystonia may develop and by
using these electrodes we try to
overcome these abnormal reasons in the
brain so what you do is you put actually
wires into the brain yeah you put
electrodes into the into the brain into
the deep brain structures and it's then
chronically stimulated with these
stimulator that are implanted into the
body either below the collarbone or into
the abdomen and it's a very effective
treatment to help patient
first generalized or segmented Estonia
and they stay there for the rest of the
life are these similar interests or they
there was returned to the stimulator
that can stay over several years and
have to be recharged like once a week
and then there are batteries and they
have to be exchanged it depends on the
current that's used but three to five
year every three to five years thanks so
much for inviting me in your training
today